de esta democracia,
y no es un defecto que ocurra cada 360 000 millones de veces
que nuestra democracia trata de tomar una decisión.
Ocurre cada vez,
en cada tema importante.
Tenemos que terminar con esta sociedad política bovina.
Tenemos que adoptar
una actitud mirmicina,
Internet dice que esta es la palabra,
la actitud apreciativa de las hormigas
que nos permite reconocer este defecto,
salvar a nuestra especie, a nuestro demos.
Si conocen a Aaron Swartz,
saben que lo perdimos
hace un año.
Fueron unas 6 semanas
antes de dar mi charla TED,
y le agradezco mucho a Chris
que me pidiera dar esta charla TED,
no por poder hablar ante Uds.,
aunque eso fuera genial,
sino porque me sacaba de una gran depresión.
No podía describir esa tristeza
porque tenía que concentrarme.
Tenía que concentrarme en lo que les diría a Uds.
Eso me salvó.
Después de los murmullos, del entusiasmo,
del poder surgido de esta comunidad,
empecé a anhelar una manera menos estéril,
menos académica de abordar estos temas,
los temas de los que estaba hablando.
Empezamos a centrarnos en Nueva Hampshire
como destino de este movimiento político,
porque las primarias de Nueva Hampshire
son realmente cruciales.
Había un grupo llamado Rebelión de Nueva Hampshire
que empezó a plantear cómo poner
en el centro este tema de la corrupción en 2016.
Pero otro ser cautivó mi imaginación,
una mujer llamada Doris Haddock, alias abuelita D.
El 1 de enero de 1999, hace 15 años,
a los 88 años, la abuelita D empezó a caminar.
Empezó en Los Ángeles
y empezó a caminar hasta Washington, DC,
con un cartel en el pecho que decía:
"Reforma al financiamiento de campañas políticas".
18 meses después,
a los 90 años,
llegó a Washington, seguida por cientos de personas,
incluyendo muchos congresistas que llegaron en auto
a menos de 2 km de la llegada
para caminar con ella.
(Risas)
Yo no tengo 13 meses
para caminar por el país.
Tengo 3 niños que detestan caminar,
y una esposa que
detesta cuando me ausento
por razones misteriosas.
Por eso no era una opción,
pero me pregunté
si podíamos imitar un poco a la abuelita D.
¿Y si caminamos no 5000 km
sino 300 km por Nueva Hampshire
en enero?
Así, el 11 de enero,
el aniversario de la muerte de Aaron,
empezamos una caminata que terminó el 24 de enero,
día de nacimiento de la abuelita D.
Unas 200 personas se sumaron a esta marcha,
conforme recorrimos Nueva Hampshire de arriba abajo
hablando de este tema.
Y lo sorprendente para mí,
algo que no esperaba encontrar,
fue la pasión y la ira
compartida por las personas con las que hablamos del tema.
Mediante una encuesta vimos que el 96 % de los estadounidenses
creen importante reducir la influencia
del dinero en la política.
Los políticos y los expertos dicen
que no puede hacerse nada,
que en EE.UU. no se preocupan,
pero debido a que
91 % de los estadounidenses
cree que no se puede hacer nada.
Y esta brecha entre 96 % y 91 %
explica nuestra política de resignación.
Digo, después de todo, al menos el 96 %
desearíamos poder volar como Súperman,
pero como al menos el 91 % creemos que no podemos volar,
no saltamos de los edificios altos cuando
sentimos la necesidad.
Porque aceptamos nuestros límites,
y lo mismo ocurre con esta reforma.
Pero cuando le damos esperanza a la gente,
empieza a diluirse esa imposibilidad absoluta.
Como dijo Harvey Milk, si les damos esperanza,
les damos una oportunidad, una forma de pensar
en la posibilidad de este cambio.
Esperanza.
Y esperanza es lo que nosotros, los amigos de Aaron,
le negamos, porque hicimos
que perdiera esa esperanza.
Amo a ese muchacho, como amo a mi hijo.
Pero le fallamos.
Y amo a mi comunidad,
y no le voy a fallar.
No le voy a fallar.
Mantendremos viva esa esperanza
y lucharemos por ella,
sin importar lo difícil que parezca la batalla.
¿Qué sigue?
Bueno, empezamos con esta marcha de 200 personas,
y el año próximo, habrá 1000
en distintas rutas
que marcharán en enero
y se concentrarán en Concord para celebrar esta causa
y luego en 2016, antes de las primeras,
marcharán 10 000 personas por el estado,
y se reunirán en Concord a celebrar esta causa.
Y conforme marchábamos, en todo el país
nos preguntaban: "¿Podemos hacer lo mismo
en nuestro estado?"
Así que lanzamos una plataforma llamada G.D. Walkers,
o sea "Granny D Walkers" [caminantes abuela D]
y habrá caminantes de la abuela D en todo el país
marchando por esta reforma. En primer lugar.
Segundo, en esta marcha,
uno de los fundadores de Thunderclap, David Cascino,
estaba con nosotros,
y dijo: "¿Qué podemos hacer?"
Así que desarrollaron una plataforma
que anunciamos hoy,
que nos permite reunir a los votantes
comprometidos con esta idea de reforma.
Independientemente de dónde se encuentren,
dentro o fuera de Nueva Hampshire,
pueden registrarse y recibir información
de las posturas de los candidatos sobre este tema
para poder decidir por quién votar
de acuerdo a quién
hará realidad esta posibilidad.
Y para terminar, número tres, lo más difícil.
Es la era del comité de acción política (Súper PAC)
De hecho, ayer, Merriam anunció
que acuñará la expresión "Súper PAC".
Ahora es una expresión oficial del diccionario.
El 1 de mayo, alias May Day,
haremos un experimento.
Vamos a lanzar una acción política
que creemos es un Súper PAC para
poner fin a los Súper PACs.
Y esto funciona así.
El último año hemos estado trabajando
con analistas y expertos políticos
para calcular cuánto costaría juntar
suficientes votos para una victoria en el Congreso de EE.UU.
y hacer así posible la reforma.
¿Cuánto? ¿USD 500 millones? ¿USD 1000 millones?
¿Cuánto?
Y luego, cualquiera sea la suma,
lanzaremos un financiamiento colaborativo propio
porque no se puede usar KickStarter con fines políticos,
como sea, un financiamiento colaborativo,
primero una campaña en las bases
donde las personas contribuirán con pequeñas sumas
supeditadas a lograr objetivos muy ambiciosos
y cuando se logren esos objetivos,
pasaremos a los grandes contribuyentes,
para hacer que contribuyan a hacer posible
que ejecutemos las acciones políticas
para ganar en este tema,
y cambiar la influencia del dinero en la política.
El 8 de noviembre,
ayer lo descubrí, es el día
que Aaron cumpliría 30 años,
el 8 de noviembre,
celebraremos 218 representantes
en la Cámara y 60 en el Senado,
en el Senado de EE.UU.,
comprometidos con esta idea
de reforma estructural.
Anoche escuchamos deseos.
Este es mi deseo.
Mayo [May] "1".
Puedan [May] los ideales de "1" muchacho
unir a una Nación detrás de una idea crucial
de que somos un solo pueblo,
somos el pueblo al que se le prometió un gobierno,
un gobierno que prometieron
dependería única y solamente del pueblo,
que, como nos dijo Madison,
que un rico no valga más que un pobre.
"May 1" [Mayo 1, Pueda uno].
Ojalá puedan sumarse a este movimiento,
no porque sean políticos,
no porque sean expertos,
no porque sea su campo,
sino porque si existen,
son ciudadanos.
Aaron me lo pidió.
Ahora se los pido yo a Uds.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)